in april the biden administration issued
sanctions against the russian government
over cyber attacks that had targeted
american agencies and major private
companies the most notable was the solar
winds hack that saw emails stolen from
various government entities from the
justice department to homeland security
as part of those sanctions the treasury
pointed fingers at a handful of russian
companies for aiding the kremlin with
its cyber espionage operations one of
those companies was positive
technologies though not a household name
in the security industry it's a
significant player providing security
services to major private and financial
organizations as well as russian
government bodies the treasury said that
not only had the one billion dollar
valued business provided cyber services
to russia's spy agencies but that its
conference hack days was a kind of
recruitment fair for the fsb
usually camera and media shy positive
ceo yuri maximov sat down with forbes
for over two hours to talk about the
accusations leveled at his company as
well as the impact they've had on
positives planned ipo
one that could value his company in the
billions of dollars our american readers
won't know much about positive and they
won't know much about you can you tell
me what is positive technologies how did
you start the company why did you start
the company and what problems are you
trying to solve
well thomas we founded the company in
2002 it tried to make sense of cyber
security and the role it could play we
started developing our expertise in the
white hat area so to speak so white hats
rather than committing crimes they
actually know a lot about crimes we
stand for security and you know we're
doing cyber security defense have you
got many customers outside of russia now
have you ever tried to get business in
america for instance
well the us market has always been
challenging to us because our products
are primarily targeting large
enterprises not even mid-sized
corporations certainly not at private
individuals we started our international
expansion around 2012 maybe 2013. we
focused on several regions including
asia europe and middle east but then
after the crimean events everything
changed
the major sanctions we're announcing
today will continue to ratchet up
the pressure on russia including the
cronies and companies that are
supporting russia's illegal actions in
ukraine
in other words today
russia is once again isolating itself
from the international community
setting back
decades of genuine progress so after
this event we actually split positive
technologies into several branches i
don't know what our life would have been
had the crimean events not happened so
one of the allegations made against
positive was that it was actually
running cyber
espionage operations
on behalf of the russian government is
that true is that is there any truth to
the accusation that the positive
actually did its own
cyber espionage campaigns against
adversaries
it's not a a nation-chinese secret
indeed we do serve a russian ministry of
defense as well as an fsb a federal
security bureau we have been developing
products that can only be used for
defense not a single product of ours can
be used you know both for offense and
defense
customers can buy a product or they can
order a service it's not that anybody
rents our people same goes for the
ministry of defense let's treat it as a
hypothetical case they can call us and
ask us to hack their defenses and that's
the only way that we sell our red
teaming services regardless of
affiliation incorporation of the
customer
all the russian companies i know
companies that are operating
internationally
they're really afraid somebody may think
they are serving law enforcement
agencies
and here in russia we have to be
extremely neutral
in order to be able to run an
international business as part of the
sanctions that you were facing the u.s
government also talked about the solar
winds attacks they allege that the
russian government was behind them do
you have any thoughts on that do you
have any ideas why the us government
would be blaming russia
i don't know if solarwinds was russian
hackers work or not the fact of the
matter is whenever there is a hack it is
very important to find a scapegoat when
russian companies are hacked we often
say no there must be a department of
homeland security right
but the danger of doing that is you
become less strict about your own
security standards well i guess it's
convenient to blame it on russian
hackers we tighten our security
standards how about we develop systems
that cannot be hacked like that
so my call to the american industry is
like this maybe we should stop the
blaming game and should finally develop
a security system that will make such
risks
unexploitable previously reports have
claimed that u.s intelligence agencies
believe positive provides hacking tools
to russian spies and that it carries out
operations on behalf of the kremlin it
was also reported that individuals
linked with a hacking crew known as
fancy bear notorious for its involvement
in the 2016 election attacks had
previously attended positives hack days
conference when the biden administration
sanctions landed it was alleged that
positive ran a conference that was
essentially a place where russian
intelligence agencies would would
recruit is there any truth in that and
positive and its conference were
essentially used as a place for spy
recruitment
now obviously we run this event not in
order for agencies to recruit anybody
there you know had i worked for a law
enforcement agency russian or otherwise
i wouldn't really consider a conference
like this as
the top watering hole
because usually we have very liberally
minded youngsters attending this event
what other
effects
have you had from the sanctions what
impact on your business
have the sanctions actually made if any
at all
they have certainly impacted our ipo
plans well because obviously american
funds very often participate in ipos but
then we aren't planning the ipo right
now we still have time to talk to afaq
and learn more about all the details so
we're not ruling out collaboration with
american funds but actually from the
very beginning we wanted to run it as a
kind of a mass-market ipo catering more
to private investors rather than big
funds if uh positive is worth roughly
two billion dollars and you own
just under half the company that either
could make you a billionaire now or soon
how do you feel about that well being a
billionaire
is more than just money right you know
in this world it's a clear cut sign of
success and if you want to work on
something grunt if you have a very high
falaten ambition you actually need
resources and you need recognition
because sometimes the ideas you have may
sound very crazy to lots of people so to
me it's also a kind of confirmation of
my success and i see it as an investment
in my future success and yes i do
consider money as a kind of resource but
i rather see it as a way of making my
dreams possible
maximoff says it's his dream to bring
russia america and the whole world
together in improving cyber security
at a time when the biden and putin
administrations are at least talking
about a digital dayton
there is some albeit still very small
chance that maximoff's grand ambition
could come to pass
you